well as Parliament desperately tries to
find a majority for something or
anything
what Labour does next on brexit could be
crucial joining us now is the Shadow
Cabinet Office minister John Trickett
thank you very much for being with us
and just had our interview with the
Chancellor Philip Hammond newspapers
full of stories about potential coos
against Theresa May I mean is this a
week that Labour will be calling a
confidence mission well look let's take
it one step at a time I mean that
interview that you just had was
extraordinary I thought the Chancellor
really signalling that they deal that
they've worked on for nearly three years
is dead he also jumped the idea of no
deal yet mrs. Mayer's held on to that
from the beginning I mean is it
government it is a government in which
the country can have no confidence but
the main thing is as he said and he is
right we are on the edge of a
catastrophe
we have to find a way through this
quickly and that is why labour tomorrow
is putting down its resolution
suggesting that we have negotiations
Jamie's already meeting people to see if
there is a way forward for Parliament
and for the country I mean I know that
some people some conservatives will be
shouting at the screen listening to you
just say that we're on the edge of a
precipice here as you say why doesn't
they for back a deal then the deal is
not acceptable to Parliament and it's
not popular at all in the country so why
not and there are obvious reasons why
the most obvious one is the problem with
a land border in Ireland in Labour's
proposed list the difference with our
proposal and their proposal is that we
would not have a border at any time in
Ireland because we'll be part of a long
term customs union negotiated by us with
the customs union in it no not in the
way that we envisage it which is a
common customs union expressly
tailor-made for Britain which would mean
that there wouldn't be a necessity for a
land border in Ireland and he is that
was a problem is the backstop is
different in this sense that the
backstop which the government's
negotiated we cannot get out of we are
handing over our sovereignty to the
European Union there's no
a natural way out of this for the
country that's good listen we want a
customs union tailor-made for ours which
will deliver proper jobs regional
development and a way forward out of
this crisis which protects jobs and also
respects the Good Friday Agreement in
Ireland that is a very important
achievement for our country the last 30
years we don't want to jeopardize it now
look the Chancellor himself is sitting
here in this very see a few moments ago
more or less dropping the deal we have
proposed an alternative set of
arrangements we think it's a reasonable
way forward but we're happy to negotiate
with others and Jeremy Corbyn is now
leading the conversations to try to find
a consensus the Chancellor also didn't
rule out the idea of a second referendum
if it meant for example tourism a still
passing and then having a public vote to
see if that would be acceptable to the
public and there was a million people
which holds marching yesterday in
support for a second referendum
why wasn't Tremec open there well he was
out campaigning a more commercially
where the cockle pickers died and what
the country wants to talk about for
instance crime was right and tried a
crime there were 20,000 less police
officers on the streets and this great
anxiety about the state of country apart
from Brazil and who is out there Jeremy
Jeremy is out there leading the country
discussing austerity and all the other
things that matter I was in London
yesterday I was in a series of meetings
but I took a bit of time I come had
conversations with people on the March
and what was interesting was there was
passion there was enthusiasm but above
all there was fear that this government
is simply lost and it's leading the
country down a blind alley into a very
very dangerous moment that was the
overwhelming impression I impression I
had it was a lovely crowd but the job of
a no to alternative government is try to
find a way of bringing all the sites
together in our country rather than
dividing it in the way that they thought
the government has on a brexit but a
bracelet which works for everybody I'm
interested to know your own views on
it's like I'm a friend and we spoke
about it the last time that you're on
the program can have a quick look
what you told us back then you said if
people feel that a privileged political
elite has decided to find a way of
reversing the previous referendum that
would cause us some difficulty and
rightly so is that what you think it is
what I think and from the beginning
there were some people who right from
the beginning didn't accept the results
of the referendum they wanted to remain
they want you to find a way of really
reversing the referendum the original
referendum that isn't Labour's position
our position is we've accepted the
results of the referendum but we think
we are now getting closer and closer to
a precipice and what we said is if we
arrive at a position where it's
necessary to prevent either a crash out
deal on or a dreadful Tory deal then at
that point we will seek to have a second
referendum by the way I am look I voted
for it labour put down a resolution as
it was in January which included a a
vote and by the way tomorrow we've got
another amendment which also includes a
second referendum but that's sorry how
would you vote if there was a referendum
I'd vote to remain and reform but we'd
have to see what other options were on
the table the truth is we are somewhere
away from making that decision look we
can spend a lot of time discussing
process how will we arrive at a decision
actually we should be discussing content
and the content is a deal which can work
which will deliver jobs and a more
prosperous country and we need to
reverse austerity and the problems which
our country's facing okay well let's
talk about the content shall we because
we just heard as well from the
Chancellor that the House of Commons
will have a opportunity to express its
view and try and find a majority around
something next week potentially through
this series of what's been known as
indicative votes so would you vote for
the Prime Minister's deal plus a customs
union as a compromise
no I think the Prime Minister's deal
simply didn't work and the main problem
we have is we've got a long term
relationship in a backs table from which
there is no exit and it's like
max Robb is a customs union but there is
no way out of it into a permanent
relationship we could be locked forever
into a situation which is something
short of what the people have voted for
and therefore we don't think that will
work
look we've made proposal it's got five
aspects to it and we are pushing it down
tomorrow night but equally our our
resolution tomorrow in front of the
House of Commons suggests that there are
a number of options which the house
should consider and I was pleased to see
the Chancellor of the Exchequer saying
actually he thinks that's what we're
going to end up look the point is mrs.
maid doesn't have the political skills
of negotiation and persuasion and charm
which is needed to win the majority of a
house where she doesn't have a majority
yourself and Jeremy is putting himself
in that position gradually emerging as a
national leader negotiating with Tories
with liberals with other parties trying
to find a way out of the message being
laid in so do you think a different
leader of the Conservative Party would
make it easier for Nate I think whatever
happens is in childhood for the Tory
party they've indeed led us into this
mess remember it was camera mr. camera
and mr. Osbourne that had the referendum
in the first place and tried to body the
country into a particular decision and I
think look the cabinet has made a mess
of this we need a general election
that's the kind of people's what we want
that's not sound like someone about to
do do with the concept we want to create
a consensus in the whole country part of
the problem is the government which has
lost its way okay John track it thank
you very much